be with him and I want to say to all the
people up north well have done
extraordinary jobs thank you so so much
and thank you for having us today to my
right is Melissa de Rosa she is the
secretary to the governor to her right
is what's your name young lady
Mariah Kennedy Cuomo who is part of my
team and it's a pleasure to have her
with me today I hope you mentioned me
more about that in a second today is
Sunday that is a fact
I know these days tend to run one and to
the other but today is Sunday and I like
to focus on the facts in this situation
because facts it was most important a
lot of people have opinions and a lot of
theories but Senator Daniel Patrick
Moynihan who was a great senator from
the state of New York like to say
everyone is entitled to their own
opinion but not his own facts so let's
give the people of the state the updated
facts this is the chart of total
hospitalizations we've been watching
this 24 hours a day for it seems like
most of our lives but it's only been
about 40 days the total hospitalization
rate is down again in the state of New
York we're down to 16,000 if you look at
the numbers we're at 18,000 people
hospitalized for a period of time it
flattened there for a while at pause
there then went down to 17,000 but this
is a low from our high point of 16,000
big question of whether we've been past
the apex past the high point and it
turned out the high point wasn't a point
but the high point was a plateau and we
got up to a high point and then we just
stayed at that level for a while but if
the data holds and if this trend holds
we are past the high point and all
indications at this point a week that we
are on a descent whether or not the
descent continues depends on what we do
but right now
we are on a descent and that's in all
the numbers the hospitalization numbers
are down
the three-day average of the
hospitalization rate is down I was
speaking to Michael and there this
that's what he's seeing in his hospital
system that's what emergency rooms
across the state are saying that they
see the the maximum inflow is less than
what it was so that all tracks with what
the numbers are saying this number of
intubations which I watch carefully
because intubations are the number of
people put on ventilators and 80 percent
of the people who are put on ventilators
don't make it so this is a very
important chart to look at and the fact
that those numbers are down is very
important this is a reality check with
all the good news and the reductions we
still have 1,300 people that yesterday
came in and tested positive and were
hospitalized 1300 is a lot of people
coming into the hospital system without
diagnosis less than it had been so
that's good news but it is still 1300
people who are testing positive and need
hospitalization we've been watching the
spread of the virus from the New York
City area and there have been little
outbursts on Long Island and in upstate
New York and we've been jumping on those
outbursts but overall we have controlled
it and the numbers are about the same
Westchester and Rockland where we had
real problems remember the first problem
was in Westchester County New Rochelle
but Westchester Rockland Long Island
upstate New York is still only about
seven percent of the cases so we're
watching for a potential spread in other
parts of the state but so far we have
contained it and we have controlled
controlled it nursing homes are still
our number one concern the nursing home
is the optimum feeding ground for this
virus
vulnerable people in a congregate
facility in a congregate setting where
can just spread like fire through dry
grass we have had really disturbing
situations in nursing homes and was
still most concerned about the nursing
homes the worst news of all for us to
live with every day and in every day
tragedy we lost another 507 New Yorkers
and those are not just very large
numbers we see that's every number is a
face and a family and a brother and a
sister and a mother and a father and
people who are in pain today and will be
in pain for a long period of time so we
remember them in our thoughts and
prayers but on this Sunday day of
reflection thank you from the bottom of
my heart and on behalf of all New
Yorkers for what the people at northwell
have done the entire team talked about
team effort this is the team effort and
to all our health care workers all
across the state 1 million health care
workers 445,000 hospital workers 160,000
nursing home workers this they have made
all the difference in the world and you
know crisis like this it tends to bring
out the best and the worst in people and
certain people can break your heart in
their response to this but on the other
hand other people can rise to the
occasion and just give you such a sense
of confidence in the human spirit and
the health care workers have done that
I've been looking at this chart for 40
days and it looks like a bar chart it
looks like numbers and a line I don't
see it as a bar chart as we've been
going through this to me it was a
mountain that just kept building and
building and building and you didn't
know where the top of the mountain was
and those numbers kept growing and we
kept going
up the mountain and we kept wondering
where is the peak where is the apex what
is the high point when does this stop
and we get to the top of the mountain
and by the way it's not a point and then
it plateaus and the plateaus at a very
very high rate which means every day
those health care workers have to come
in and they're seeing a tremendous
number of people come in the door
overwhelming the capacity of the
hospital and remember we asked hospitals
to increase their capacity 50% so if a
hospital had a 100 bed capacity now they
had a 150 bed capacity and it stucked at
that very high level on that plateau and
that was day after day after day people
who were at their max and had given it
all and then the next day it's the same
thing all over again
but they did it they got us through the
plateau and now they're getting us down
the other side and we just pray to God
that it remains down on the other side
so if there's been a lot of pain and a
lot of anguish for a lot of people but
the skill the courage and the love of
our healthcare workers of our first
responders or our police of our
essential workers they have really
gotten us through all of this we also
want to thank our neighbors ninety five
thousand medical professionals who
agreed to help in this state and outside
of this state who said they would come
and help us and I want to thank the
other states and communities who we put
out a call for help and we got help from
all across the country it reminds me for
in that post 9/11 time when we needed
help and other communities in the
Northeast needed help and people came
from all across the nation and they just
wanted to help and they just showed up
that's what happened here and that when
I talked about seeing the best and the
worst of people at a time of crisis that
outpouring of generosity I'm sure you
felt the same gave us such a sense of
evidence that we're not in it alone and
humanity and the love of the American
people was there for us and I said we
need your help today but New Yorkers
also never forget and thank you for the
help and we will be there when you need
us and we will be there when anyone
needs us right now our neighbors in
Massachusetts are looking at an increase
in cases I spoke to governor Charlie
Baker yesterday they may need 400
ventilators and we know how important
ventilators are if the numbers keep
going up and if they have to scramble
and I said you were there for us and
we're going to be there for you if they
need 400 ventilators we've already
identified them and we will bring them
over on 24 hours notice and we wish them
well and anything they need we're going
to be there so the recent news is good
that we are on the other side of the
plateau and the numbers are coming down
but that's good news only compared to
the terrible news that we were living
with which is that constant increase and
remember you still have 1,300 people who
walked into the hospitals yesterday
testing positive so it's no time to get
cocky and it's no time to get arrogant
right we still have a lot long way to go
and a lot of work to do and this virus
has been ahead of us every step of the
way we have been playing catch-up from
day one in this situation so it is no
time to relax and this is only half time
in this entire situation we showed that
we can control the beast and when you
close down you can actually slow that
infection rate but it's only halftime we
still have to make sure that we keep
that beast under control we keep that
infection rate down we keep that
hospitalization rate down as we now get
all all giver eager to get on with life
and move on so it's
/ and this we have a whole second phase
and in this second phase first do no
harm
don't jeopardize what you've already
accomplished by seeing that infection
rate increase we have to be smarter
especially when it comes to the new
frontier of testing and how we test and
how aggressively and how we get that
organized and then when we talk about
rebuilding we have to talk about not
just rebuilding but let's learn from
this horrific experience and let's take
these lessons forward and how do we
build back better than before I don't
want to have gone all through this and
then just say we're reopening no no no
we have to open for a better future than
we have ever had and we have to learn
from this and as we go through this
remember I know people are eager to get
on with life we have slowed the
infection rate down to 0.9% 0.9% means
one person infects point-9 percent of a
person less than 1 that means the virus
is slowing if one person is infecting
1.2 people the virus is increasing and
is an epidemic and an outbreak and is
out of control
so we have a very small margin of error
here as we navigate going forward any
plan that is going to start to reopen
the economy has to be based on data and
that means it has to be based on testing
and this is a new world for all of us
testing how do you get testing up to
scale how do you get it up to scale
quickly and how do you find out where we
really are right now in terms of this
virus you have all these scientists and
all these experts who are basically
trying to extrapolate from the data but
we don't really know how many people
were infected how many people had corona
virus but self resolved we don't really
know
because we haven't been able to do
testing on that large scale but we're
going to start and we're going to start
here in the state of New York with
antibody testing antibody testing means
you test a person to find out if they
have the antibodies which they would
have if they were infected with the
corona virus and we're going to do that
in the most aggressive way in the nation
where we're going to sample people in
this state thousands of people in the
state across the state to find out if
they had the antibodies that will tell
us for the first time what percent of
the population actually has had the
corona virus and is now at least short
term immune to the virus this will be
the first true snapshot of what we're
really dealing with and we're going to
be doing that over the next week in the
New York State Department of Health
we'll be running that there's also
another set of tests which are called
diagnostic testing diagnostic testing is
whether a person is positive or negative
and we're coming up to scale on this
even though it is very very hard
northwell is leading the parade on this
and I just looked at some of the
technology they're bringing in all these
different manufacturers who made
different machines to run different
tests and there's a number of big
manufacturers and and North wellas
bringing in as many as they can but this
has to be brought to scale nobody's done
testing at this level ever and we have
to do this in partnership with the
federal government because there's all
sorts of logistical questions and supply
chain questions and people can't get
certain chemicals they need to do tests
and the chemicals and mayder in other
countries so we have to do this with the
federal government I spoke to the head
of the CDC yesterday and he was very
smart and very informed and we talked
about how we can do this together
talk about being smart the federal
government is talking about passing
another piece of legislation which would
help in the reopening
and they want to help small businesses
and that's great they also have to help
state governments and local governments
which have not been supported in the
previous legislation everyone is saying
well it's up to the states to come up
with a reopening plan it's up to the
governor's up to the governor's fine and
that's true and right and legal but the
governor's in the states have to have
resources and yes you have to help small
businesses you have to help the airlines
you have to help all these private
sector interests as well as citizens but
if you don't help the state government
and local government then how are we
supposed to have the finances to reopen
and if you don't give state and local
government support you know we're the
ones who support the schools we support
the police we support the fire we
support the hospital workers we support
the transit workers so if you starve
state and local government all that
means is we have to turn around and
reduce funding to the people who we are
funding if we don't get federal
assistance you're looking at education
cuts of close to 50% in the state of New
York where school districts would only
get half of the aid they got from the
state last year you're talking about
cuts to hospitals from the state I mean
how ludicrous would it be to now cut
Hospital funding from state governments
so the governor's bipartisan Democrat
and Republican in this crazy political
environment when you can't get Democrats
and Republicans to agree on anything all
the governor's agree and have said to
Washington
make sure you fund the states in any
next bill you pass and we asked for five
hundred billion dollars again on a
nonpartisan basis we also must remember
as we go forward what we have done so
well thus far the mutuality and
discipline that we have shown I have
many school districts in the state over
700 school districts
they're calling saying they want to open
up their local schools they want to make
these decisions local officials are
calling we have beaches we have parks we
have businesses we want to make
decisions I understand the pressure that
the local school districts are under I
understand the pressure that the local
officials are under I understand the
mounting political pressure you know
people see those numbers come down
they're like okay let's go let me get
out of my house
I get it but we have to stay smart and
we have to stay united now is no time as
I said to get arrogant we're working
with our regional states our partners
New Jersey Connecticut etc the
surrounding states we're coordinating
with them and we have to continue to do
that the weather is getting warmer the
numbers are coming down happen fever is
getting worse
I believe that's going to be a
documented disease when this is over
cabin fever but we have to stay smart
and we have to stay coordinated we've
been working with the New Jersey and
Connecticut because whatever one state
does affects other states right you live
in now so you live in Suffolk you live
in New York City you can get in your car
and be in New Jersey you can be in
Connecticut in a matter of minutes so
it's very important to plan accordingly
it's not that we can be on the same page
on everything but at least let's know
what each other is doing so for example
on state parks we're coordinating what
our policies are because you could see
people go from one state to another I
was in Albany yesterday talked to a
couple who drove up from Queens for Thai
food to Albany and I said you came up
for Thai for Thai food from Queens you
know it's a two and a half hour ride and
they said yeah we just we had to get out
of the house I suggest for Thai food you
know in Queens they have Thai food also
very good time
Queens but it just shows how people need
to get out and do something so we get it
New York state parks are open New Jersey
they're closed Connecticut they're open
New York our beaches are closed in New
Jersey the state beaches are closed some
of the local beaches are open
Connecticut they're open Connecticut
marinas are open and New Jersey in New
York also so staying coordinated with
our partners is very important and it's
important within the state also I get
the political pressure that everybody is
under I get the political pressure that
local officials are under but we have to
be smart and we have to be coordinated
people have to have the best government
from government officials in the state
of New York government matters today in
a way it is not mattered in decades and
it's important that government sends the
right signal and one message and there's
no confusion because if people don't
have confidence in government right now
if they think there's chaos or confusion
or politics that that would be a
terrible message to send we've done a
great job as government officials all of
us Democrat Republicans state local we
have to keep doing it and now is not the
time to send mixed messages and also on
a very parochial level I get that in the
conversations I've had people for
political pressure here's the simple
answer this state's emergency powers now
govern in this emergency blame me blame
me somebody's complaining about a beach
somebody's complaining about whatever
business is open schools open blame me
it's true it's right it's the state law
and I don't have any issue with that so
blame me
also as we're planning the reopening
let's set a ball the bar a little higher
and let's all start to think about this
now what did we learn during this
personally what did we learn socially
what did we learn collectively what did
we learn and how do we incorporate that
into our reopening right how do we have
a better healthcare system when we
reopen how do we have a better
transportation system but better
telecommuting a smarter telemedicine
program better technology and education
how do we have more social equity you
can see the disparate effect of this
disease and how it reinforced the
disparity and that inequity in society
how do we remedy that and how are we
more cohesive as a community for having
gone through this right so it's not just
reopened it's not just build the back
it's advanced use this as a moment in
time where they look back when they
write the history books and they say boy
they went through a terrible time but
they actually learned from it and they
improved from it and they moved forward
we had 9/11 yes we built back we built
back difference we built back smarter we
had hurricane sandy devastated Long
Island I was governor I didn't say we
want to replace I said we're gonna learn
how to do a new grid system we're gonna
learn how to do better infrastructure
and we did Long Island today is better
for having gone through hurricane sandy
as terrible as that was we have to do
the same thing here how do we come back
even better so the long and the short of
it is thank you to all New Yorkers for
all the good work to our health care
workers a special thank you to the
police fire to the transit workers you
know the economy has not been closed
down right all the essential services
have still been functioning you still
could go to a grocery store and get food
lord knows you could go to a health care
institution and get health care the
transportation work the buses worked all
these people who kept everything working
we thank them from the bottom of my
hearts our hearts but also remember we
still have more to do and New Yorkers
know that because New Yorkers are tough
but tough doesn't mean just tough tough
is easy it's tough but smart but
disciplined but unified and but loving
and that's who we are as New Yorkers
last point on a personal point I have my
daughter Mariah who was with me and she
is the third daughter for me and she
just came home if you will she was
quarantined so now I have all three
daughters with me and they can't
appreciate this but it's such a comfort
to me personally to have them home you
know when your child is not at home
especially at a difficult time like this
you're always wondering where are they
are they okay are they doing what's
right and every instinct is you want to
be able to protect them and when they're
not there you have this constant hole in
your heart right in this constant
question as you're going through the day
so you're trying to do everything that
you have to do but you still have this
question in the back of your mind
where's Mariah how she so that they are
now all three with me gives me a great
sense of comfort and in this crazy
situation we're in but for the craziness
I would never have my three daughters
with me again you know that 25 25 22
years old the last thing they want to do
is hang out with pop right they have
places to go people to see you know
they're they're taking life by the horns
so I get this beautiful silver lining in
the midst of this hell where my
daughters are with me again and we get
to celebrate family and we get to bring
back true
additions and we get to enjoy each other
and have really in-depth conversations
that we even haven't had in years right
and reconnect in a way we haven't had
the opportunity in years today is Sunday
and I come from an Italian American
household where we had a great tradition
on Sundays the family had to come
together at the table you had to be
there they called the dinner but it
started at two o'clock in the afternoon
it was somewhere in that I don't really
know why they called it dinner but you
everybody was at the table spaghetti and
meatballs every Sunday
I started my tomato sauce before I left
we're gonna go back we're going to sit
at the table have our spaghetti
meatballs on Sunday and I know what I'm
going to talk to them about my daughters
Mariah and Mariah brought her a
boyfriend who's also here the boyfriend
is very nice and we liked the boyfriend
advice the father's the answer on what
you think of the boyfriend is always I
like the boyfriend always because
there's only two options either you like
the boyfriend in which case you say I
like the boyfriend or you don't like the
boyfriend but you can never say you
don't like the boyfriend I learned this
lesson the hard way otherwise it
triggers nds nds is natural defiance
syndrome it's not documented but it's um
it is a psychological condition where if
you say as a father I don't like him na
natural defiance syndrome kicks in and
then they like the boyfriend more
because he is opposed by the father so
the answer has to be I like the
boyfriend in this case I actually liked
the boyfriend but even if you don't like
the boyfriend the answer can only be
that I like the boyfriend but we're
going to be at dinner with the boyfriend
and we're gonna have our spaghetti and
our meatballs they won't eat the
spaghetti in the meatballs because they
when I cook it they just won't eat it
but they move it around the dish
that's all I can ask but I'm going to
tell them we're gonna recall to them how
important that meal was on Sundays to
have the family together to take the
time to sit and to talk and to reconnect
people talk about the Italians and they
love the food yeah they love the food
but the food was just a magnet to get
the family to the table right it was
just the device to get people to spend
two hours at the table and that's where
you talked and you you went through the
week and I used to do it at my
grandfather's house my father mother my
kids we used to all the siblings would
go to my grandfather's house my
grandfather's name was Andrea I'm named
for him Andrew and at the end of the
meal my grandfather would always say he
was at the head of the table he would
say okay that was my vacation and then
he would get up and they would do
whatever they were doing I never really
understood what he meant and later in
life I said to my father who was his son
I said what did grandpa mean that was my
vacation he said what you're gonna
father never had a day off your
grandfather worked seven days a week you
ran a little grocery store delicatessen
in Jamaica and he worked seven days a
week and he was saying that was his
vacation he never took a vacation and
everybody would take a vacation on TV
and the TV commercials that was his
vacation the three hours at the table
for dinner with his family that was his
vacation and then he would go back to
run the store you think of how our
immigrants work in this country and
wherever the immigrants are from what
that whole immigrant philosophy and
drive does for us and Island where I
started you think of all the essential
workers you know well we had to stay at
home I'm tired of staying at home yeah
think of all the people all the
essential workers who had to go on
there everyday and work in the middle of
this who frankly would have much rather
stay home and they didn't know what the
virus was and they're out there working
with the public exposing themselves why
do we have a higher rate of infection
among african-americans Latinos etc well
who were the essential workers we have a
higher rate of infection among the
essential workers because they were out
there driving the buses and they were
out there driving the trains and they
were out there running the hospitals and
the emergency rooms and the nurses and
the police officers they didn't get to
stay home and they got sicker and they
died more than anyone else because they
were there honoring their
responsibilities to their job and to
public service and let's remember that
and let's remember them yeah we're all
going through a tough time and it is a
tough time but a lot of people have
shown a lot of courage and a lot of
beauty and they've had very tough lives
and let's appreciate them at the same
time
any questions for myself or Michael
Dowling or Melissa DeRosa
no questions from Mariah Kennedy Cuomo
because that would be trouble I'm just
kidding
the witch copied the hook I don't know
why the Cova tracker would not be up to
date that's the first I've heard it but
I will check it should be up to date
because the numbers I just gave you the
up to date numbers so I can check why
they don't have that on their website
the FDA has approved the state's
antibody test that's what we're going to
be rolling out this week now that we
have the approved test we're going to be
rolling it out to do the largest survey
of any state population that has been
done and we'll take thousands of tests
antibody tests over this next week all
across the state to give us a real
snapshot a real baseline of exactly how
many people were infected by coronavirus
and have the antibodies so we'll have
the first real statistical number on
exactly where we are as a population you
know they talk about herd immunity we
talk about infection rate and we're all
trying to extrapolate from that but we
have not had hard data on where we are
and that's just one of the testing right
it's diagnostic testing is are you
positive or negative how do you do that
fast how do you do that large antibody
testing tells you if you had the virus
and or passed it and this whole world of
testing is complicated this is going
through northwell all these different
manufacturers make a very big expensive
machine and then each manufacturer has
their own tests and you have to buy that
test
from that manufacturer and then you have
to buy the chemicals that go with that
test and Northwest have you know seven
ten different machines from different
manufacturers that are all running
different tests and each one of those
tests the trophic ovid but you have to
go back to that manufacturer and get all
the new supplies to run the tests and
that is what gets very complicated and I
go back and forth with the federal
government on this we have to figure it
out the states can do the tests but when
I go back to the manufacturers they will
say I can't find the reagents the
chemicals that are used in the test well
how do you get more reagents I have to
get them from China I have to get them
from this country I have to get them
from this country I can't help them do
that I can't do an international supply
chain and that's where the federal
government has to help because no state
can do that and the same manufacturers
who are selling to me through New York
they're selling to Chicago to California
to all these other states so everyone
has to do their part I know it's hard
and I know it's complex but everything
we're doing here is complex to follow up
afterwards on the on the testing and
machines we saw and how that works the
look nobody can say what anyone can say
anything god Bless America
it's my grandfather would say god Bless
America First Amendment anyone can say
anything
so yeah anyone can say anything right
it's conspiracy theories everybody is a
theory
patrick moynihan god rest her soul
anyone can have an opinion not anyone
can have their own facts
anyone cannot have their own facts facts
or facts opinions opinions so yeah some
people say coronaviruses a hoax yeah god
bless america
600 people died two days ago 500 people
those are real deaths that's real that's
a fact
that's a fact okay sixteen thousand
people in hospitals who test positive
for corona virus that is a fact I don't
care what you think or what your opinion
is that is a fact
so you can't say it's a hoax because
that is a fact okay so that's a fact
and I'll leave that at that people are
anxious they see the numbers coming down
you exhale a little bit and they should
exhale look I was afraid nobody said
that we can stop the growth of the virus
people said we think maybe you can if
you do socially distance and you close
down and you do master but nobody said
we know for sure so my fear was always
we'll do all this and the virus will
still increase that would have been a
really bad place to be you did
everything you could you closed
everything down and the virus continued
to spread that would have been really
frightening that didn't happen
we controlled the Beast we apex I toad
it's coming down the other side that is
good news
okay so we exhale we can control the
Beast
yes but the Beast is still alive we did
not kill the beast and the Beast can
rise up again we know that this is a
temporary reduction in the virus rate
the virus rate is wholly dependent on
what you do you tell me what you do
today out
the infection rate three days from now
you tell me what you do today as a
society I'll tell you how many people
are going to walk into a hospital three
days from today it is purely contingent
on what we do well the numbers of them
we have to get out of the house we have
to get back to work I need a paycheck I
get it but you go back to where we were
infection rate will go up that
hospitalization rate will go right back
up again
so all this with a calibration how do
you start to reopen start to increase
activity start to bring people out make
sure they socially distance etc make
sure you're doing it intelligently so
you start to reopen but watch that
hospitalization rate in that infection
rate because if that starts going up
again and you don't immediately correct
or you made such a dramatic movement
that the virus infection spreads you
could go right back to where you were in
one week's time and if we went through
all of this and lost all of these people
and forced essential workers and
hospital workers to do unbelievable
tasks to get us through this crisis and
we recreate the crisis then shame on us
my Clinton was protesting knowing the
machines and the reagents and the supply
chain
we have to keep one-sided I'm working on
diagnostic testing and another whole
side of the lab develop changing and
filling the building to capacity to
develop the antibody testing the goal is
to do the maximum amount of testing as
we probably as we possibly can because
that's the way we can the economy can
get to reveal reopened and healthcare
can get to be reopened if you don't do
the testing so the governor said and you
make a - quicker move to open - quickly
then you can walk into the scenario
where the governor just described that
will be one of the most dangerous things
that could ever possibly do thank you
remember the context here the we have
accomplished what no one thought could
be accomplished the top experts the CDC
the president's coronavirus task force
they all had multiples of more
infections projected and
multiples of more deaths projected CDC
coronavirus White House Task Force they
were talking about 2 million people
hospitalized in this country just a
month ago 2 million people you know how
many hospital beds we have in this
country
1 million their low estimate was for
double the hospital capacity of the
nation on like March 13th that's what
the top experts were predicting here in
New York State
McKenzie Cornell Columbia the gates
funded operation they all had multiples
of what we did this is a great success
story on everyone's behalf
you know people weren't so angry and
frustrated right now this has really
been a great triumph what the federal
government did what the states did what
the health care workers did the way
Americans responded and acted
responsibly it is better than any of the
predictors President is right when he
gets up there and says the models had
many more people dying presidents right
all the experts said that so this was
heroic efforts that changed that curve
god Bless America
but don't under a piece of under
appreciate what you just did and don't
go backwards that would be a real
mistake
secondly efforts to alleviate bodies
coming into fewer rooms and thirdly the
I've taken a lot of actions during this
period of time the action that probably
has caused me the most amount of grief
is what I said about marriages marriages
you can now do you can get a marriage
license online and we've authorized
marriages online by any licensed or
legal official who can perform a
marriage
so I said yesterday well no one has any
excuses anymore right now it's a simple
yes or no will you marry me simple yes
or no you lose all those possible
excuses well I have to set a wedding
date I have to do this and you do it
tomorrow it's all online you can get
your certificate you can get your
license you can do it online the judge
can do it any official can do it so
there's no excuses anymore yes or no
when you marry me I got all sorts of bad
ugly comments about that the Melissa
will I'll ask her about if she knows
anything new about funeral homes do I
have faith in the president look what
the federal government did working with
States as I just said was a phenomenal
accomplishment we bent the curve we
flattened the curve government that if
people did it but government facilitates
people's actions right we had to double
the hospital capacity in New York State
that's what all the experts said
president brought in the Army Corps of
Engineers they built 2,500 beds at
Javits that Mykel in North world were
operating was a phenomenal
accomplishment close to a thousand
people have gone through Javits luckily
we didn't need the 2500 beds but all the
projections said we did need it and more
by the way so these were just
extraordinary
efforts and acts of mobilization and the
federal government stepped up and was a
great partner and I'm the first one to
say we needed help and they were there
state and local governments were
fantastic the hospital system was
fantastic fantastic New Yorkers were
fantastic and that is an undeniable fact
supposed to look at what they said was
going to happen
CDC coronavirus task force Cornell
McKinsey all of them and they had a line
up here and the actual line is down here
what do you owe the variance to heroic
efforts on behalf of people as
facilitated by government federal and
state so that was phase one now we have
to go forward to Phase two big challenge
is going to be testing it will not be
done perfectly we can't bring it up to
scale in this period of time I will tell
you that but we can do better working
together than working apart and that's
the federal state partnership I will do
my part as a governor I know the other
governors will do their part federal
government is involved in testing they
had a whole presentation at the last
presidential briefing we have to work
together and do the best we can and we
will and I have faith that we will
because we have in the past to allow
funeral directors who are either retired
or from out of state to be able to be
licensed immediately in New York to help
with some of the backlogs on the
wedding's yesterday the executive order
that we did allowed clerks to perform
the weddings remotely and today the
governor signing a new executive order
to allow anybody who is license to be
able to perform weddings to be able to
do it so it won't just be limited to
clerks and on the website it'll be
updated by two o'clock today the coab
website tracker I can also I'm also
licensed to perform weddings so I am
available for online services special
vows that I do did you know that I would
have assumed it let's take one more
question
just a photo over that president and I
have one other unrelated question he
tweeted during your press conference
that he was right on ventilators now
he's right by vesting governor's must
step up and get the job done you will be
with you all the way did you speak with
the president recently today yesterday
of that with this and has there been any
move toward movement with getting more
Regents or the diagnostic testing we
have been talking about I haven't had a
conversation with the president in the
past day about this but we've had
conversations about it in the president
is right he's right states have to do
what they have to step up on testing and
the federal government has to step up on
testing federal government is involved
in testing and they did a whole
presentation at the president's briefing
on testing and what they're doing on
testing and what they're doing on
helping the supply chain etc and that's
great and between the states working
with the federal government we will do
the best job we can what was the
president's tweet I am testing with you
all the way great states must do their
part and the federal government must do
its part perfect that's what's called
partnership I agree it just as a follow
up on the testing I know that initially
there was some rationing of the
diagnostic testing what is it going to
look like for the antibody testing who's
going to be getting those and Google
being available who will be able to get
the
testing once that gets wrapped up the
testing that we're doing now this week
is is a random sample so it's not like
testing where somebody can ask to be
tested it has to be a random sample that
is conducted throughout the state
thousands of people get tested so we
know this percentage of the population
had the antibodies that is not a test
where a person can call up and say I
want to be tested or go to a place that
has to be done on a random sample basis
in terms of the antibody testing being
added to the diagnostic testing we now
have a an antibody test that the state
can perform we can do about 2,000 tests
per day for the state that's about
14,000 per week sounds like a big number
it's not that big a number in the total
context of a state of 19 million people
also when you talk about testing just to
give it a relative proportionality we
have tested in this state more than any
state in the United States we have
tested more than any country has tested
okay on a per capita basis so nobody is
better at testing than we are with all
the testing we've done since this
started five hundred thousand tests Wow
it's a lot not really it's been a month
and we did five hundred thousand at that
rate this goes on for three months we
would have tested 1.5 million people we
have nine million people in the
workforce we have 19 million people in
the population so we have to increase
that rate and that's why the partnership
with the federal government to get the
reagents etc is so important and that
the federal government provides the
states with resources to do this
I mean you have the president saying 15
times it's up to the governor's it's up
to the governor's is up to the
governor's and then they're gonna pass a
piece of legislation that gives you know
what two states zero zilch nada niente
whatever like would you want to say it
nothing but then how would the state's
supposed to do this and then what you
know what happens I'll tell you exactly
what happens the state now has about a
15 billion dollar deficit somewhere
between ten and fifteen billion dollars
deficit I'm going to have to I don't
have any funding to do what I normally
do I normally fund schools you'll see a
50% cut in education you'll see it cut
to hospitals in the midst of all of this
I give local governments aid they pay
the police officers they pay the
firefighters they pay the bus drivers
public transit those are the essential
functions that are now working how can
you not fund that well we want to fund
some more business great fun small
business from the airlines fund whatever
you want but how do you not fund the
state government that you know is in
charge of reopening this entire nation
right so we have to be smart I want to
thank Michael darling again I want to
thank North well and all the people not
just for today's hospitality but more
importantly for all the beautiful work
that they have done thank you very much
Hospital funding by 50% raise taxes to
the world you have the ability to do
rolling cuts did not include no we're
raising taxes so why can't you read